Land und Brecht
[Musik]
Richard schönen guten Morgen ja guten
Morgen Markus wo erreiche ich dich in
der altbekannten Kemenate guck mal nach
langer Zeit mal wieder ne ja so ganz
langsam beginnt ja der Advent und die
Weihnachtszeit und dann wird selbst in
der Kriminalität
ein bisschen aufgeräumt okay also bis
zur Kerze wenn ich noch nicht gekommen
also da wusste ich auch gar nicht wo ich
die hinstellen soll aber wisst du so ein
Romantiker hast du so Kerzen zum Tee ja
ja also ich habe da so schöne
Kindheitserinnerungen bei uns wurde der
Advent so schön zelebriert ja mit
Ovomaltine trinken
ja und ähm Kätzchen essen ja genau und
es wurde uns fast vorgelesen ah ja schön
dieses dieses Vorlesen ne ich weiß gar
nicht ich finde das eigentlich
heutzutage noch so richtig statt also
wird vielen Kindern noch vorgelesen weil
wir letztes Mal auch so schön über und
so weiter gesprochen haben ich weiß das
gar nicht
ich weiß das auch nicht also ich habe ja
bei meinem Sohn großen Wert darauf
gelegt immer gerne gemacht der fand das
natürlich auch gemütlich total und eben
hat das auch gefallen aber dann gönnen
natürlich auch zwei zu also das Kind dem
gerne vorgelesen wird ne und die Eltern
die gerne Vorlesen er ist richtig ja ich
fand halt immer das war so der Moment in
dem ich immer dachte da entsteht jetzt
die Kreativität ne in Mannheim noch so
gut gemacht haben Film Kinderfilm der
liefert die halt alles ne der liefert
dir Bild und Ton und im Grunde ist die
Fantasie dann zwar dabei und und
wahrscheinlich würden Forscher sagen das
ist ganz enorm was da passiert aber das
Feuerwerk das das passiert wenn du dir
das Bild selber ausdenken musst ist das
ein großer Unterschied ja genau das ist
wirklich ein großer Unterschied ne ich
sag ja mal lesen ist denken mit Fremden
Gehirn ja das ist dieser Art von
Training die kann man in keiner Form
irgendwie bekommen wenn man wenn man
Filme denken mit Fremden Gehirn apropos
ich hatte dieser Tage war das Gefühl ich
muss man dann jetzt wirklich in
Sicherheit bringen Fußball WM in Katar
der Wahnsinn um diese Binde der der
Wahnsinn um diese ganze WM Gianni
Infantino der
unvorstellbare Interviews gibt der
monologisiert eine Stunde
was geht dir denn durch den Kopf wenn du
auf diese Weltmeisterschaft guckst mir
geht der Ärger darüber durch den Kopf
dass man das alles das schon ahnen
konnte vor zwei Jahren oder vor einem
Jahr und dass man damals noch hätte
verhindern können dass diese
Weltmeisterschaft stattfindet und dass
ich die Empörung merkwürdig finde wenn
sie ganz kurz vorher vor der WM ist wenn
die kritischen Filme erst kurz vor der
WM tatsächlich laufen und nicht ein Jahr
vorher oder ein halbes Jahr vorher und
dann also die Empörung dann am größten
ist wenn sie nichts mehr nützt
und ich hatte ja immer die Vision dass
ich gedacht habe es braucht doch nur ein
paar wichtige fußballländer geben ganz
wenige ja fünf
Großmächte ja vier Europäer ein
Südamerikaner die sagen wir fahren nicht
nach Katar dann hätte die
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft definitiv
nicht stattgefunden weil dann hätte die
mit diesem Makel leben müssen und was
ich nicht verstehe wenn die FIFA jetzt
hingeht und die Verbände erpresst und
sagt ihr dürft die so ein loftbinde
nicht tragen ja und wir bestrafen euch
wie gelben Karten als hätte man
Unsportlichkeiten begangen ja da kann
man doch einfach sagen jetzt reicht uns
das Affentheater wenn wir die nicht
tragen dürfen reisen wir ab ja es sind
sechs Länder dabei ja die zwei hätten
sich ja nicht qualifiziert Schweden und
Norwegen die waren ja auch Vertreter
sozusagen dieses binden Bündnisses und
wenn diese sechs Länder einfach sagen
pass mal auf ne wir können uns am Arsch
lecken wir fahren wenn wir die nicht
tragen dürfen da wäre die FIFA blamiert
dann müsste man gar nicht ob das Turnier
weitergeht dann wäre Katar bleiben wird
die selbst die FIFA überhaupt noch
weitergeben würde tatsächlich wäre es
die Frage also das ist die Frage
jedenfalls nicht überleben
und ich meine wir hätten alles erreicht
was man auch nur bestenfalls für den
Fußball erreichen kann warum knickt der
DFB ja und die anderen Verbände die ja
zusammen mächtiger sind als FIFA oder
der wm-veranstalter der sowieso die
ganze Zeit nach Luft wegen weil nichts
funktioniert wie er sich das gedacht hat
warum macht man von dieser macht keinen
Gebrauch
der ist das ist das ganz große Rätsel
das ist gratis Mut und gratis Moral
haben wir letztes mal schon darüber
gesprochen oder vorletztes Mal die man
dann so nutzt um im Vorfeld große
Sprüche zu kloppen und sagt das auch das
machen wir dann so und das ziehen wir
danach durch und dann knickst du auf den
allerletzten Metern ein jetzt werden
Juristen gefragt ne unvorstellbar ja
tanzt sondern gleichen man kann ganz
einfach sagen wir laufen nicht auf wenn
wir die Biene nicht tragen ich meine
wird die FIFA dann hingehen und wird
Deutschland vom Tunnel Turnier
suspendieren und wenn dann die anderen
fünf Länder auch noch solidarisch sind
wie sieht denn dann die
Weltmeisterschaft aus ja du schreibst
Sportgeschichte wenn du es machst ne
wenn du durchziehst wenn du schreibst
Sportgeschichte du wiederholst nicht den
Fehler von 1978 über den wir gesprochen
ich will nicht dass man nachher der DFB
nach der Weltmeisterschaft groß rum
erzählt was für ein Fehler das gewesen
ist also man hat jetzt die Möglichkeit
Eier zu zeigen
[Gelächter]
ja
wir brauchen Eier ganz genau jetzt in
dieser Frage hat aber das ist das
entscheidende hast du hast du ich was
die Titanic nicht weil ich glaube es war
die Partei Martin Sonneborn hast du
gesehen die Karikatur es war großartig
so eine Mauer und die die ähm die Mauer
die eine deutsche Mauer die da steht ja
auf dem Fußballplatz und die Hände aber
weg von sensiblen Teilen ja ja
die Zeile endlich keine Angst mehr vor
dem Freistoß und runter DFB-Team spielt
jetzt ohne Eier
[Gelächter]
weil ich leider sehr lustig aber erklär
es mir Richard was ist das ist das ist
das sozusagen wieder unsere
ist das wieder diese Heuchelei ist das
wieder diese die
diese Moral die wir dann immer wie so
eine Monstranz vor uns hertragen um am
letzten Moment dann doch all die
Kompromisse zu machen die wir sowieso
immer machen wenn wir auf jeden Fall ist
es keine feministische Werte geleitet
Außenpolitik auch nicht ohne Eier ja
wird auch dadurch nicht und es ist
einfach ein Zeichen dessen dass man muss
sich überlegen die DFB liegt ganz großen
Wert auf Wert ja ja Fairness als großer
Wert Integration als großer Wert
Toleranz als großer Wert und so weiter
ich meine sein Schicksal Sohn sehr mit
der FIFA zu verknüpfen ja an der Werte
mäßig nichts zu retten ist kann
langfristig den DFB nur schaden
und gegen die FIFA aufzubegehren wäre
auch für das Image des DFB absolut
wichtig und ich frage mich was sind das
für Menschen die den DFB führen die das
nicht sehen die sich also irgendwie
immer noch in einer Art
Schicksalsgemeinschaft mit der FIFA
sehen das ist das was ich nicht wirklich
verstehe habe muss ich sagen ich habe ja
keinen Einblick hinter die Kulissen des
DFB ich weiß auch nicht mit welchen DFB
Vertretern du bist ja gesprochen hast
und wie man das jetzt immer noch
rechtfertigen kann ja also Oliver
Bierhoff sagt irgendwie ich glaube
Oliver Bierhoff war es der sagte ne
unsere Werte bleiben unsere Werte und
die werden wir auch weiterhin vertreten
da gut die Gelegenheit dafür ist günstig
auch sehr günstig wie werden sie an dem
messen was sie was sie sagen glaubst du
denn mal ganz realistisch wie das
weitergeht glaubst du dass Infantino das
überlebt glaubst du dass die FIFA in
einigen Jahren noch ist was jetzt ist
weil ich habe das Gefühl und das finde
ich jetzt so schöne Überleitung zum
Thema Bildung das ist Systeme gibt
die noch so morsch sein können ja aber
trotzdem einfach nicht richtig
reformfähig sind ja ist das sehe ich da
würde ich dir gerne antworten mit mit
einem großartigen Satz den ich neulich
von von Hemingway glaube ich gelesen
habe der war irgendwann mal pleite und
dann wurde er in einem Interview gefragt
wie das denn sein kann dass so ein
großer Autor wird so viele Bücher
verkauft pleite gehen kann und wie das
passieren konnte und Hemingway sagte
first gradually and dance
langsam und dann ging es ganz schnell
und das ist so ich glaube das könnte der
FIFA auch passieren
das wäre ja schön ja
hoffen wir das weiß auf Satelliten jetzt
nicht noch Jahrzehnte warten müssen nee
es suddenly ist dann auch schon sehr
schnell ich glaube das ja wirklich das
haben wir doch in den letzten
Jahrzehnten so oft gesehen die letzten
Jahren gerade in einer dazu nehmenden
kritischeren und aufgeklärten
Öffentlichkeit wird es immer schwerer so
seine kleinen Schweinereien so links und
rechts aber die FIFA untersteht keine
richtigen umrissigkeit das ist egal aber
wenn das Image erstmal richtig hinüber
ist und das Geschäftsmodell plötzlich
wackelt aber dann müssen doch diejenige
die das Geld eine reinbringen ja wie zum
Beispiel die deutsche Nationalmannschaft
und all die anderen Nationalmannschaften
da muss es doch an denen liegen dieses
System zu kippen das gibt doch nicht von
oben
also ich fand die Wert schon ja nicht
von der FIFA geleistet sondern die
Wertschöpfung entsteht ja dadurch dass
die wahre Fußball so wertvoll ist
deswegen weil es Länder gibt Spieler
gibt ja die hervorragenden Fußball
spielen klar aber wenn die wenn die
Nahrungskette wenn du die Nahrungskette
zerstörst von unten her dann wird
irgendwann schwierig deshalb mal so wenn
wenn Zuschauer nicht mehr gucken dann
kann ein Fernsehsender nicht mehr so
viel Geld für Fußballrechte ausgeben
dann kann die FIFA nicht mehr so viel
Geld ausgeben um irgendwelche Leute
Gefüge ich zu machen und dann wird's
ganz schnell ganz ganz schwierig und
noch ein Satz zu ihrer an diese Jungs
die da stehen und einfach die Hymne
nicht singen nicht mehr singen das Leben
Gänsehaut das wirklich hundertmal aber
hundertmal mehr Eier als bedürfte mit
einer lastbinde auf dem Platz zu gehen
und eine gelbe karte
Richard wir haben letztes Mal über
Bildung gesprochen ich fand es total
interessant mit dir über Bildung zu
reden du bist ja jemand der sich über
Bildung wahnsinnig viele Gedanken
gemacht hat und finde man sollte diese
beiden Systeme nicht miteinander
vergleichen aber wir reden über Systeme
die man verändern müsste und dann vielen
Punkten Reform brauchen und ich habe ich
habe nach unserem letzten Gespräch noch
lange
darüber nachgedacht und habe bin zum
Gedanken gekommen wenn du heute einem 14
15-Jährigen 16-Jährigen ja wenn wenn der
gesagt kriegt pass auf ich bin der
Erwachsene ich bin der Lehrer ich sag
dir so wird die Welt jetzt morgen
funktionieren da musst du doch als heute
14 15 jähriger total misstrauisch werden
und einem Erwachsenen nicht allzu sehr
vertrauen denn ich habe mittlerweile den
Verdacht dass die Erwachsenen von heute
die Welt von morgen gar nicht mehr
verstehen
[Musik]
ist es umgekehrt ich glaube dass die 14
15-Jährigen den Erwachsenen heute viel
mehr und besser zuhören und auch gerne
zuhören oft im Vergleich zu der Zeit
sagen wir mal ist die 68er Generation 14
oder 15 waren ja weil die haben gesagt
ihr seid moralisch diskreditiert
Generation des Dritten Reiches und so
weiter die Adenauerzeit
Zweiten Weltkrieg Drittes Reich
rollokaust und so weiter und die haben
gesagt von euch lassen wir uns überhaupt
nicht erzählen was die Welt von morgen
ist und was die Zukunft ist heute habe
ich dieses Gefühl nicht ich habe eher
das Gefühl dass die 14 15-Jährigen
hoffen dass es halbwegs irgendwie so
weitergeht wie das Leben ihre Eltern war
und das ist nicht in irgendwelche ganz
schrecklichen Zeiten kommen das heißt du
hast zwar Recht in der Sache aber ich
glaube nicht so sehr in der
Sozialpsychologie das ist ein guter
Punkt ich will auch was anderes hinaus
ich hätte ich will sagen
wir also wir beide unsere Generation die
Generation nach unserer Eltern wir haben
doch die Welt deswegen irgendwie ganz
gut glaube ich verstanden weil sie sich
sehr langsam verändert hat ja aber jetzt
im 21 Jahrhundert hat diese Veränderung
eine Geschwindigkeit aufgenommen diese
unvorstellbar und wir kommen nicht mehr
mit das heißt wenn die heute an
Erwachsener was erzählt ich ich stelle
mir das immer vor dann steht da einer
wie ich ja gesagt oh Gott der Opa
erzählt mir jetzt irgendwie wie es läuft
und was soll der denken soll kann der
denken okay das ist jetzt schlau das ist
sozusagen Lebensweisheit ja was ich dem
jetzt angedeihen lasse oder es ist
einfach nur dummes Klischee Gelaber und
nix wert also vor der Frage stehen die
doch
[Musik]
es ist völlig richtig also die
wissensbeständigen
erfahrungswissensbestände die altern
unglaublich schnell genau also es gibt
einen ein schönes Wort das in dem
Zusammenhang fast nie verwendet wird
aber dass mich mal sehr beeindruckt
hatte der Philosoph Hermann Lübbe hat
mal das Wort gegenwarts Schrumpfung
erfunden ja er hat gesagt also
gegenwarts Schrumpfung ist kann man
daran sehen wie schnell wissen veraltet
und er brachte damals schon in den 90er
Jahren das Beispiel dass in den
bio-wissenschaften quasi alle sieben
Jahre die Erkenntnisse komplett auf den
Kopf gestellt werden das war damals
Gentechnik Reproduktionsmedizin und so
und das gilt natürlich im Grunde
genommen heute nicht nur für solche
fachwissenschaftsbestände sondern über
ganz vieles was wir über das Leben
denken oder was immer so sichere Blöcke
waren oder feste Koordinaten und
Glaubensbekenntnisse erfahrungsregeln da
ist was dran also ich glaube wir leben
tatsächlich in einer Zeit rasanter
Gegenwart Schrumpfung ja und das lässt
Wissen wahnsinnig schnell altern und
auch Erfahrungswissen ganz schnell Alter
ja also wenn du über Technologie redest
wie disruptiv das alles ist von einem
Tag auf den anderen verschwinden
plötzlich Dinge tauchen neue Dinge auf
jetzt bist du 15 Jahre alt auf welche
Technologie sollst du Vertrauen und noch
schwieriger jetzt kommt dieser
15-jährige der dein Sohn ist eine
Tochter ist die kommt zu dir und frag
Dich Papa worauf soll ich denn Vertrauen
verstehe ich das ich verstehe es doch im
Zweifel noch viel weniger als sie oder
er
also ein technischer Hinsicht gebe ich
meinem Sohn sowieso keine Ratschläge
und die Frage was von Vertrauen kann was
sind Vertrauens
zählige wollte ich schon sagen
Seiten im Internet den man vertrauen
kann vertrauenswürdige Plattformen
welche Technologien soll man benutzen
welche lieber nicht und so weiter ich
würde niemals behaupten dass ich mich da
auskenne und das wirklich zu wissen
müsste man hochgradiger Spezialist sein
der sich mit fast nichts anderem
beschäftigt
und das heißt das Leben hat bekommt auch
ein immer größeren Blackbox Charakter
genau ne also auf der einen Seite wird
es immer und durchschaubarer wenn es
immer und durchschaubares muss man immer
mehr Vertrauen und wenn man immer mehr
vertrauen muss hätte man ja gerne
Anhaltspunkt ja man vertrauen kann
Kriterien ja und selbst diesen schwer
genug zu finden richtig
deswegen für Jugendliche Kinder von
heute bei allen Möglichkeiten die das
Leben so bereithält dass eine echt
herausfordernde Zeit ne in der diese
Generation groß wird finde ich immer
wahnsinnig
herausgesprochen dass auf der einen
Seite die lebensoptionen die größten
sind die es hier in der Geschichte der
Menschheit gab ja man kann alles machen
man kann in Neuseeland studieren wenn
man will und motiviert genug ist man
kann Startup Unternehmen gründen und
irgendwo seine Zelte aufschlagen in Balo
Alto und was weiß ich was aber man kann
das auch alles bleiben lassen man kann
auch alles was ganz anderes machen oder
von dem wieder das Gegenteil und diese
Multi optionsgesellschaft das ist ja was
das was es früher nicht gab also ich war
für mich war die Frage studieren
Wuppertal oder in Köln ich kam auch
Solingen ja ich hatte ganz ganz wenig
Geld ja ich konnte mir jetzt nicht ohne
weiteres vorstellen wie ich irgendwo in
der Ferne Fuß fassen sollte also so
platt wie das noch war sondern irgendwas
was man erstmal von zu Hause erreichen
kann und dann kann man ja weiter sehen
und das ist so anders als das heute ist
und diese diese vielen Möglichkeiten
sind Chancen aber auch eben die enorme
Chance das falsche auszusuchen für sich
das falsche aussuchen nicht das Richtige
zu finden vielleicht gibt's ja auch das
richtige gar nicht und deswegen ist das
tatsächlich so klingt immer doof ne wenn
man das dann sagt mit Ende 50 aber ich
möchte nicht mehr 15 sein ach doch das
weiß ich gar nicht aber das ist noch mal
ganz anderes Thema ich würde mal gerne
Richard ein Punkt diese Frage des
auswendig lernen ist erinnerst Du nicht
wir beide haben na ja nach der letzten
Folge noch mal uns darüber unterhalten
dass das nicht schlecht ist dass das
nicht schlecht ist und ich würde jetzt
gerne mal einen Gedanken in die Runde
werfen
ich sag mal die Zeit der Klosterschulen
ja in Kloster Neustift da wo ich zum
Beispiel auch zur Schule gegangen bin
dein Tirol
wenn man sich das mal angehört hatte das
waren Bildungsstätten ja da haben wir
die Dekor Herren dort immer erzählt wie
wie wichtig das ist da ging es darum
wirklich Wissen zu vermitteln und das
war für mich unendlich wertvoll weil ich
als als jemand der
ganz normales Arbeiterkind ich hatte
nicht so diesen Zugang zu Wissen einfach
rein physisch auch nicht ich hatte nicht
die tollen Bücher zu Hause ich hatte
nicht den Zugang zu den tollen
Bibliotheken ich konnte nicht mehr
Knopfdruck sozusagen wissen einfach
haben deswegen war für mich wichtig mir
wissen wirklich zu erarbeiten und
deswegen war es wichtig einfach wirklich
wissen in mich quasi rein zu stopfen
damit ich irgendwie in diesem Leben mich
zu Recht finde heute haben sich die
Dinge ja fundamental auf den Kopf
gestellt du kannst ja dein Leben dreimal
verbringen indem du einfach Wikipedia
liest und dann hast du erst Wikipedia
gelesen
das heißt wissen ist in einem
unendlichen Ausmaß verfügbar und jetzt
kommt jemand wie Bob Blume kennst du den
das ist ein Lehrer Blogger Buchautor
interessanter Mann der der viel online
Unterricht macht und so weiter und der
sagten total guten Satz der sagt dieser
Stoff Fetisch ja der in meiner Zeit Sinn
gemacht hat dieser Stoff Fetisch heute
der killt das Lernen weil nämlich auf
diesen Stoff immer mehr und immer mehr
und noch mehr drauf gekommen ist und der
killt mittlerweile komplett den Spaß am
Lernen an sich ja das ist so also wie
gesagt Alter Renaissance Weisheit ja
Kinder wollen nicht viel besser gefüllt
werden sondern wie Fackeln entzündet ja
ja dass die der der Gedanke immer mehr
und immer mehr und immer mehr ist am
Ende immer weniger ja weil Stoff der
darüber haben wir lange geredet der
nicht mit Neugier aufgenommen wird der
bleibt am Ende auch nicht hängen ja der
ist da nichts anderes als negative
Belastung geführt dazu dass man Hyper
cortisoliert ja dass man also schwitzt
und zappelt und negativen Stress hat und
und keinen Spaß an nichts mehr und so
weiter also eigentlich müsste man ja
hingehen und müsste die Stoffmenge
reduzieren ich sage ja immer
Reinhard Karl ne einer der großen
Bildungsexperten in Deutschland der sagt
ja immer den Stoff muss man den Dealern
überlassen
in dem Moment wo so richtig spannende
Dinge ja wie der Erzberg im Norden von
mir aus ja wenn die zu Stoff werden ja
dann wird sozusagen aus dem frisches
duftenden Brot Zwieback ja als Stoff ist
alles langweilig wenn mein Sohn hat
gesagt wenn du mir von Geschichte
erzählst ne aber viel darüber geredet
von dem punischen Kriegen und was weiß
ich was und so weiter dann ist das
spannend aber wenn wir das in der Schule
machen ist das so langweilig
ja dann gibt's dann irgendjemand der hat
sich dann didaktisch da drei Fragen
nicht so ausgedacht und dann muss man
genau das was in diesen Fragen ist das
muss man dann antizipieren das muss man
wissen worauf es dann ankommt ja man
darf sie nicht für die Sache begeistern
aber man muss wissen warum wird mir die
erzählt was könnte davon geprüft werden
irgendein Fachdidaktiker hat sich
überlegt was man anhand dieses Stoffes
veranschaulichen kann der Lehrer muss
das dann befolgen und dann wird
sozusagen das alle Würze raus also man
könnte ja selbst ein Fußballspiel in der
Schule ja so langweilig besprechen und
eine Klausur darüber schreiben dass
keiner mehr Lust hat im Fußball ja das
hat Blume auch Blume ist etwas auf
interessanter Gedanke ich kann nicht in
der achten Klasse 150 Jahre Geschichte
durch Peitschen und gleichzeitig Dinge
vertiefen digitale Medien dazu ziehen
und individuell arbeiten dann sagt er
diese Bildungspläne heute sind einfach
zu überladen und weißt davon
interessanten Begriff hinaus aus der
corona-zeit wo Kinder Schüler echt
gelitten haben und das wird jetzt erst
so langsam klar in welchem Ausmaß sieht
das wirklich getan haben sagt aber Gerd
da gab es den Begriff des
kernkurriculums ja da haben uns gefragt
was sind wirklich die wichtigsten Dinge
worauf kommt es jetzt an und er sagt man
müsste sich jetzt jedes Fach vornehmen
und dann mit einem auch weinenden Auge
beinhart die Dinge benennen auf die man
einfach verzichten kann ist ein schöner
Gedanke also mir gefällt das mit dem
kernkurriculum und dann muss man auch
noch zwei Dinge unterscheiden Pflicht
und Kühe also es ist ja auch für die
Lehrer schade ne wenn also die Lektüre
die man in der Schule macht pflichtmäßig
vorgeschrieben ist im achten Schuljahr
macht man das und dann weiß ich nicht ob
man wahrscheinlich immer noch kleider
machen Leute ja und dann max Frisch
haben wir schon mal drüber geredet und
das ist alles sozusagen fest bestimmt
was man macht genau wie schrecklich ist
das für ein Lehrer jedes Jahr die
gleichen Bücher machen zu müssen
also wäre es ja gut wenn man sagt wir
haben so ein miniaturgerüst so drei vier
pflichtsachen aber dann darüber hinaus
auch die Möglichkeit dass der Lehrer was
eher toll findet oder geeignet findet
oder somit reinfließen zu lassen und das
könnte man was ich am Beispiel der
Lektüre mache auch in vielen anderen
Fächern machen in Physik ist das nicht
so einfach ne in Mathe auch nicht aber
was sie den deutschen Unterricht gilt
das kann natürlich auch für das was man
liest im Fremdsprache Unterricht gelten
das kann auch individuelle Schwerpunkte
in Geschichte setzen einfach mal ein
paar Wochen was was man wahnsinnig
spannend findet was ein bisschen abseits
der klassischen gute ist zu machen also
wir müssen das Mischungsverhältnis aus
Pflicht und Freestyle verändern dann
wird es auch für die Lehrer wieder
interessant gut gibt noch einen
interessanten Gedanken von von Blume
deshalb ist total gute these er sagt man
könnte
ernsthaft eine Schule wie 1955 machen in
der alles digital ist du kaufst Sie
einfach an Whiteboard stellt sich dann
als 90 Minuten am Stück irgendwas und
dann ist der Unterricht zwar toll
digitalisiert aber es ändert sich
trotzdem richtig richtig das ist das ist
immer die die spannende Geschichte also
wenn wir über Digitalisierung in der
Schule reden dann reden wir über
Hardware dann jammern wir über die
schlechte Ausstattung der Schulen und
über zu langsamen Netze und solche Dinge
wir reden aber nie über Software und
zwar Software im übertragenen Sinne wir
reden nie über die Frage zu welchem
Zweck wie und mit welchem Gewinn lassen
sich die Mittel der Digitalisierung in
der Schule einsetzen
ich denke ja zum Beispiel das ist eine
Idee die es mir gekommen als ich sei man
kann gelesen habe sei man kann es ein
pakistanischer
Unternehmer der wahnsinnig erfolgreich
in USA war und der kostenlose
Lernsoftware für die ganze Welt
bereitstellt die kann Akademie heißt das
ja und in Indien sind sind 100.000 ja
Millionen von Straßenkindern haben auf
diese Art und Weise die Möglichkeit
gehabt Schulabschlüsse zu machen ja über
diese virtuelle kann Akademie die sonst
überhaupt keine Schulbildung gehabt was
ist die Idee dahinter ist total spannend
also macht er keinen Spaß
zum Beispiel ich habe da gesehen wie
Leute leben dann läuft dieses läuft in
irgendeiner Pommesbude ja in unserem
Fast Food stand da läuft das und dann
dann fangen die Kinder an und gucken das
und machen das und können das dann
irgendwie zu Hause und dann werden die
auch gefördert von der Akademie und dass
sie dann reinkommen in diese Welt und
dass sie am Ende Schulabschlüsse
schaffen das und da ist mir eins klar er
sagte man kann doch alles virtuell haben
und das sehe ich nicht ganz so aber es
ist auch nicht das Wichtigste das
Wichtigste ist dass es aber Fächer gibt
bei denen dessen absoluter Segen ist
weil man durch das virtuelle lernen
durch digitale lernen dass individuelle
Lerntempo besser berücksichtigt und das
geht zum Beispiel für Fächer für die man
genuinen keine Mitschüler braucht Mathe
ist das beste Beispiel ja also es gibt
ein Reiz von Mitschülern bei Mathe wenn
du total gut bist und mit anderen an
irgendwelchen tollen Projekten arbeitest
aber um in der Mittelstufe ja analysis
zu machen brauchst du keine Mitschüler
jeder weiß das noch aus der Schule ja
die besten drei in der Klasse ja die
können dazu wieso alles die brauchen
auch den Lehrer nicht ja und wäre der
Lehrer so gut wie die wäre
wahrscheinlich nicht Martin Lehrer
geworden
das untere Drittel ja kann im zehnten
Schuljahr die binomischen Formel nicht
erkennen und anwenden ja und wie der
Lehrer muss für alle in der Klasse den
gleichen Unterricht machen so das
gleiche Schwierigkeitsniveau nach dem
gleichen Ziffernsystem warum macht man
das nicht individuell am Computer mit
zur Lernsoftware kein Akademie gibt es
auch noch vieles andere ja da kommt ein
Nobelpreisträger der erklärt einem den
Satz des Pythagoras und dann macht man
Anwendungsaufgaben und wenn ein Fehler
ist dann erscheint er wieder und sagt
der Fehler passiert ganz leicht der
passiert immer wenn das und das und dann
lernt man in seinem eigenen
individuellen Tempo und wenn etwas
richtig kompliziert ist man hat trotz
besten erklären nicht verstanden dann
kommt der Matte Lehrer setzt sich neben
ein ja wie er nach Hilfe Lehrer und kann
ein individuell Coach
das wäre ein Segen für die Lehrer es
wäre ein Segen für die Schüler und es
hätte den Vorteil ja dass die weniger
begabten ultimativ gefördert werden und
die Hochbegabten ultimativ gefordert
werden
und das wäre eine Antwort auf diese
Frage die wir haben wo sollen ja mal die
ganzen Schweizer Spitzen ITER alle
herkommen ja dadurch dass man sie
rechtzeitig von den weniger begabten
trennt genau und das ist natürlich
wunderbar zu machen durch die
Digitalisierung weil das was wir da in
den Klassen im Moment haben das ist ja
quasi Informatik Sozialismus nennst du
das ja genau ne dass du diese
Gleichmacherei und das ist ja die die
total spannende Frage kannst du mir mal
sagen Richard warum tut sich das ist mir
schon sehr früh aufgefallen auch als ich
nach Deutschland gekommen bin warum tut
sich Deutschland so wahnsinnig schwer
damit zu sagen pass auf da gibt es jetzt
Leute die sind besonders gut in Mathe
und Informatik oder sind einfach
generell besonders gut und besonders
schlau und die ziehen wir uns jetzt und
um die kümmern wir uns ganz besonders
also wirklich Elitenförderung was ich
immer feststelle ist sozusagen dieser
Wunsch der ja als Gedanke als Idee sehr
sympathisch ist dass man sagt mir darauf
Menschen sind erstmal gleich und wir
behandeln sie auch gleich und wir
bevorzugen keinen und wir benachteiligen
auch keinen und es darf auch keine Rolle
spielen aus welchem Elternhaus der kommt
ja sozialer
Aufstieg und auch auch bildung darf
keine Frage des des Elternhauses sein
und so weiter mir ist das alles
prinzipiell sehr sympathisch ich bin mir
aber nicht sicher ob es am Ende wirklich
das Beste aus unseren Kindern
herausbringt also ich würde mal
folgendes sagen das ist eine
Frontstellung aus den 60er Jahren da bin
ich auf der einen Seite aber die Schule
kann also
nicht ganz Abitur muss immer immer
schwer bleiben ja damit nur wenige das
schaffen aber die sind da noch richtig
gut und die kann man auch gebrauchen und
dagegen gab es dann den Impuls jedes
Arbeiterkind muss Abitur machen können
studieren lernen und so weiter so das
waren die damalige Diskussion Gymnasium
und Gesamtschule und so und was an
dieser Diskussion
völlig veraltet ist obwohl es in der
Politik immer noch diese Schablone
gibt ist das ist doch kein Widerspruch
wenn ich eine Schule mache die
individuell fördert und zwar jeden da wo
er stark ist dann mache ich sowohl
Elitenförderung auf der einen Seite wie
dass ich jedem Kind gerecht werde auf
der anderen Seite und da kann die
Digitalisierung wie ich am Beispiel des
matheunterrichts gezeigt habe auch ein
wertvollen Beitrag zu leisten sie kann
das nicht alleine ne die Digitalisierung
ist nicht die Lösung unsere
schulproblems sondern sie ist ein
schönes Hilfsmittel was man geschickt
einsetzen kann genau aber die alte
Diskussion wo es um die Frage ging jedes
Kind ultimativ fördern oder
Elitenbildung ich verstehe ich verstehe
gar nicht warum das in Widerspruch ist
ja weil er aus dem einen wird nachher
ein Bundesligaspieler ja und aus aus dem
anderen wird ja jemand der wunderbaren
malen kann aus dem anderen wird ein
empathischer Altenpfleger und aus dem
anderen wird ein spitzenformatiker aber
jetzt haben wir die Situation alle also
ein System das alle Schüler zwingt das
gleiche zu lernen das ist der Fehler so
das ist der Fehler im System Talente
werden nicht wirklich vorangebracht ja
und die die uninteressiert sind werden
Menschen denen sowieso Matte und
Informatik für den Rest ihres Lebens
egal
ich meine wie viele Leute gibt es auch
in meinem entfernten Bekanntenkreis die
ihren Kindern in Mathe in der Schule
nicht helfen können obwohl sie mal Abi
gemacht haben so ja und die er war schon
im achten Schuljahr raus sind wo ich
mich immer gefragt habe wir haben die
jemals ihr Abitur geschafft ja also ihre
irgendwie so mit abschreiben und
irgendwie durchkommen und ja verstanden
okay das ist ungefähr die Aufgabe ich
würde ja gerne mal diese Tests machen ne
ich habe ja beim letzten Mal schon
gesagt wichtig ist was man sehen 20 30
Jahre später kann ich würde gerne mal in
meiner meiner jahrgangsstufe ja 100
Abiturienten würde ich mal hingehen und
würde mal Mathe Klausur elfte Schuljahr
und einfach mal wie viel Prozent werden
in der Lage das zu schaffen das sind
natürlich welche bei dass die die
nachher auch was abverwandtes studiert
haben die das können aber der ganze Rest
da würde mich mal interessieren die dann
nachher Geschichte studiert haben oder
zur Stadtverwaltung gegangen sind das
würde mich interessieren wer das noch
könnte die einzigen die das eventuell
könnten während die ihren Kindern
geholfen haben durch die Schule zu
kommen genau und die ist dann beim
Nachhilfeunterricht selbst erstmal
richtig begriffen haben genau ich ich
würde wahnsinnig gerne an dem Abend
kommen aber ich habe leider jetzt schon
einen Termin ich habe keine Zeit das
muss
natürlich schade wahnsinnig gerne aber
ich kann leider nicht ja ja
andere Schulkonzepte Mund ist sorry
Maria montessorii
gibt kriegt das auch so mit viele Leute
die die merken dass das System an vielen
Stellen sehr viele Haft ist und anfangen
nach anderen
Schulformen zu suchen
mundhistorischer Name der mir dabei
immer wieder runterkommt ja zu Recht zu
Recht also warum also die
Reformpädagogik ja Bewegung Anfang des
20 Jahrhunderts da kennt man Maria
Montessori oder Peter Petersen ja oder
Kerschensteiner es gibt so ein paar
Namen die ein in Erinnerung sind Maria
montessorius der schönste dieser Name
und diese Leute hatten damals schon die
Einsicht dass Kinder individuell lernen
sollten die hatten auch die Einsicht
dass man nicht alle Kinder je nach
Eltern gleich machen soll als Peter
Petersen im Prinzip ist ja das Kinder am
meisten von Kindern lernen und warum man
nicht Kinder unterschiedlichen Alters in
einer Klasse unterrichten sollte
interessant Maria montessorius Grundsatz
war das Kind ist ein Baumeister seiner
selbst das heißt also hier geht's
wiederum nicht darum wie ein fast zu
füllen ja sondern Anleitung zu geben und
die wichtigste Voraussetzung ist dass
das Kind das eben auch gerne lernen will
und dieses gerne das muss unbedingt
gepflegt und erhalten bleiben
so und das waren alles wunderbare
Gedanken und die hat nur einen einzigen
Nachteil
sie wurden in einer Zeit geboren wo es
keinen Bedarf an kreativen Kindern gab
ja also man muss sich mal den
preußischen Staat vorstellen steht da
mal gegen Zeit ja und jetzt kommen
lauter Kinder als Baumeister ihrer
selbst und verlassen irgendwann die
Schulen in Deutschland ja er davor hat
hätte sich der preußische Staat ja der
Untertan haben wollte gut funktionieren
unter dann ja und keine mündigen Bürger
nur gefürchtet und das war in Italien
natürlich nicht anders ja und das war in
in England so und in Amerika überall
kalten was worden war der große Papst in
den USA und der Philosoph John Julie ja
ein großer Wegbereiter moderner
Pädagogik aber alles zu einer Zeit als
der Bedarf an solchen Kindern nicht da
war heute leben wir in der Zeit wo wir
genau an diesen Kindern ein riesigen
Bedarf haben oder ein solch
ausgebildeten junge erwachsen und das
hat sich gegenüber früheren Zeiten
verändert und deswegen ist das alles
natürlich viel zeitgemäßer als die
Pädagogik der Polster schon Angestellten
Gesellschaft die DNA unseres heutigen
Schulsystems bildet kennst du andere
Stern
André Stern andere Stern ja den habe ich
mal getroffen das ist also der
faszinierendsten Menschen den ich hier
begegnet bin
in Paris geboren ist fast mein Alter und
das ist ein wahnsinnig faszinierender
Mensch und ich weiß noch der saß in der
Sendung ist schon ein paar Jahre her und
erzählte davon dass er einfach nie eine
Schule besucht hat und wir schreiben uns
ab und zu mal also er schreibt mir viel
mehr als ich ihn bedauerlicherweise weil
andere ist eine sehr treue Seele und ich
mag den unheimlich gerne weil weil das
so ein umfassen gebildeter
herzenswarmer einfach netter Mensch ist
Musiker Komponist Autor kann toll
Schreiben der kümmerte sich wieder um
Gitarren dann fängt an Gitarren zu bauen
und so weiter
und ich weiß noch ich hatte damals
diesen Gedanken was ich komme aus einer
ganz anderen Welt bei mir ging es immer
wirklich ans Eingemachte und kriege ich
komme ich irgendwie durch kann ich
meinen Alltag irgendwie bestreiten ja
Existenzsicherung und deswegen auch
immer diese Existenzängste und was mich
an andere Stellen immer so fasziniert
hat war genau das dass dieser Mensch so
angstfrei obwohl er eigentlich in meinen
Augen die die Fähigkeiten die du
brauchst um Dich irgendwie zu behaupten
und durchzukommen ja die hatte der meine
Augen gar nicht und dachte immer boah
das geht schief der wird irgendwann
fürchterlich
fürchterlich Scheitern in seinem Leben
aber der scheitert nicht der geht ganz
entspannt und heiter durchs Leben und es
funktioniert für ihn aber weißt du noch
ein Gedanke Richard weißt du wer der
andere ist diesbezüglich ist Joe Kelly
die gesamte Kelly Family ist im Grunde
so aufgewachsen
genauso die sind die haben sich selber
unterrichtet die haben sich ab und zu
mal irgendwelche Privatlehrer gegönnt
aber eigentlich sind das alles
Autodidakten und das sind alles alles
sehr
lebenstüchtige faszinierende
interessante Menschen mit Joe habe ich
ja mal sehr viel Zeit verbracht als kann
man natürlich
aus anderen Gründen also auch eine
wahnsinnig spannende Kindheit ja und
dann waren sie ganz viele Geschwister
sind natürlich ganz stark an ihnen
gereift aber die Lebensumstände aber
normale Bildung die Kinder nicht in die
Schule zu schicken sehe ich natürlich
nicht die Lösung nein nein nein nein ich
will nur um Gottes Willen nicht dass das
falsch verstanden
ja da muss man mal überlegen was hätte
der den Einzelkind was hätte der den
gespielt ja wenn die Kinder anderen
Kinder alle in der Schule sind gut dann
hätte ich den jetzt ganz ehrgeizig
unterrichtet ja so wie der alte James
sein Sohn John Stewart
ja unterrichtet hat und gesagt hat ich
mache ein Hochbegabten aus meinem Sohn
ja und das hat er geschafft ja also John
Stuart will bei der bedeutendste
englische Philosoph des 19 Jahrhunderts
nur wusste gar nicht dass man das so
Ansagen kann das ja das war richtig mit
Ansage also das war richtig vor der Welt
veröffentlichkeit gezeigt so entstehen
Genies ja und das ärgerliche daran ist
dass John Stuart Mills Zeit seines
Lebens ein wahnsinnig unglücklicher
Mensch war das kann mir vorstellen und
da ist es nicht so wichtig ein Genie zu
sein es ist wichtiger ein glücklicher
Mensch Mensch zu sein genau und wenn man
jetzt jemanden nur alleine unterrichtet
stelle mir mal vor dann dann wäre das ja
mein Sohn wäre keimt wie eine Keller
Kartoffel das hat den ganz lang weißen
Triebe entwickelt ja der wäre in den
Dienstag in den ich besonders gut bin
auch besonders gut und ich kann ja
einiges also ich hätte ihm vieles
beigebracht und wo ich nicht so gut bin
hätte ich sicher Freunde gehabt ihn
unterrichtete aber hätte der gelernt mit
Mädchen umzugehen der hätte einen Humor
entwickelt den er nur mit sich selbst
und mit mir teilt das hätte ich im Leben
nicht weitergeholfen er hätte eine
schwere karnevalsfixierung ganz ganz
unbedingt ja wäre ein ein Narr geworden
meines Busch
nein nein aber das große Problem das
große Problem ist doch wirklich der
wichtigste Grund warum man in die Schule
geht ist weil man da soziales Schach
spielen lernt ja du lernst mit anderen
Kindern umzugehen die Erwartungen zu
bilden deine Erwartungen auf andere
Stimmen ja du erwartest nie du lernst
Niederlagen einzustecken du wirst ein
trainiert in Gruppen psychologischen
Prozessen in group Verhalten und Aufruf
Verhalten du lernst ja Freunde zu suchen
Freunde zu behalten du musst damit
umgehen Freunde zu verlieren diese
ganzen Dinge sind so wichtig und so
prägen fürs Leben die sprechen alle
gegen diese Entschuldung außer du hast
wie bei der Kelle
irgendwie 25 Geschwister oder so dann
hast du ja quasi dein Klassenzimmer zu
Hause
Kind das nicht in die Schule geht das
ist schon ein Problem das ist schwierig
ich wollte eigentlich nur auf den
Gedanken hinaus dass das
Montessori Maria Montessori wird die
Idee sich selber sozusagen zu
ertüchtigen
dass das scheint zu funktionieren also
wir Menschen sind offensichtlich zu mehr
in der Lage als uns vielleicht das
Bildungssystem manchmal so zutraut
darauf wollte ich hinaus auf jeden Fall
und und eben die Rolle des selber
machens genau also es gibt ja
verschiedene Formen von lernen natürlich
gibt es lernen dadurch dass ich zuhöre
und was verstehe ja aber ganz
entscheidender Prozess des Lernens
findet in dem Moment statt indem ich
Dinge tue na dann kann ich überhaupt
erst erkennen ob ich das kann ob ich das
nicht kann und wenn ich Spaß daran habe
und etwas lernen will ja weil ich ein
Ziel vor Augen habe dann lerne ich am
allermeisten um da mal ein schönes
Beispiel zu machen ne so als jemand der
ja Germanistik studiert hat
ich war entsetzt als ich sehr gesehen
habe dass man heute noch genauso im 8.9
Schuljahr in der Schule wie wir das
gemacht haben Gedichte zerlegt und zwar
Sekt ja du kriegst also das ganze tote
machwerkwissenschaftlicher Zergliederung
an die Hand ja um auf ein armes zartes
Gedicht Herr niederzugeben ja also wir
werden gruselige Wörter wie Jambus an
der Pest Trochäus und Daktylus an den
Kopf geschmissen die werden was von
kreuzreimen und umschließenden Reimen
und so weiter erzählten braucht der
Mensch ja genau so und das alles zu
einem Lebensalter wo 90% in der Klasse
fast alle Jungs jedenfalls mit Gedichten
überhaupt nichts anfangen können also
gar nicht wissen die nicht gut ist und
was das soll ja und dann hinzugehen und
das zu zerlegen macht keinen Sinn wenn
man es anders machen würde also was ich
machen würde wäre Gedichte schreiben
lernen genau ja ich meine mit achten
Schuljahr ist man schon das ein oder
andere Mal verliebt gewesen ja oder hat
über den Tod nachgedacht oder ähnliches
und das Bedürfnis das irgendwo in
passende Worte zu finden das ist ja da
und wenn du jetzt hingehst ja und und
ganz allmählich das aufbaust wie man
Gedicht aufbaut und dann kannst du wenn
Hassan Liebesgedicht schreiben will ja
also wie ist das wenn du alleine denkst
oder was weiß ich was ja und was
möchtest du gerne du möchtest gerne
anfassen du mich sie gerne umschlingen
ja dann machst du einen Reim der das
ausdrückt ja ein umschlingenden Reim ne
Laila sozusagen eingefasst und deine
Arme sind die beiden reine dumm rum und
wie macht dein Herz wenn du alleiner
denk noch das bum bum oder macht das BUM
BUM BUM BUM BUM BUM BUM BUM BUM das ist
ein nackte Lust ja und damit kannst du
das zum Ausdruck bringen das heißt das
was vorher tut es Machwerk
wissenschaftlicher Zergliederung ist
bekommt plötzlich einen Sinn genau ja
und wenn man das so macht muss man
nachher nicht der größte Poet unter der
Sonne sein aber da hat man ein bisschen
was von Gedichten
ist doch wunderbar wenn man wenn das
Ziel sogar am Ende noch erreicht werden
sollte
dass sie zumindestens
berührt ist ja deswegen Richard Schule
dieser Raum den wir alle als Menschen
brauchen um uns zu entfalten und uns
auch darin sozusagen geschützt und
geborgen zu fühlen deshalb wichtig wie
müsste sich dieser Raum diese Schule wie
müsste sich das Verändern wo müsste man
ansetzen Punkt 123 du hast mal 12 Punkte
aufgezählt die Wahl wichtigsten also
tatsächlich versuchen individuelles
Lernen möglich zu machen
also weg vom preußischen Sozialismus und
vielmehr individuelle
Entfaltungsmöglichkeiten
ein zweiter Punkt ist die Organisation
müsste sich insofern ändern also ich
würde sagen so sechs Jahre Grundschule
finde ich gut dass sie den meisten
europäischen Ländern so damit wenn ich
mit holzhackerischer Sicherheit meinem
zehnjährigen entscheiden ob der jetzt
aufs Gymnasium soll oder nicht da würde
ich ja mindestens bis 12 warten und dann
wäre als nächstes wichtig dass man
projektbezogen arbeitet ist ja auch ein
klassischer Gedanke aus der
Reformpädagogik was heißt man hat
pflichtbereiche die jeder machen muss ne
also jeder der die Schule verlassen hat
der soll Grundkenntnisse in Mathe haben
das ist auf jeden Fall klar der soll
sich in Deutschland in einer anderen
Sprache gut ausdrücken können und so
diese Ziele gibt es aber es gibt auch
auch mehr Projekte die man wählen kann
dass das von der projektautomotor ist
oder dass das Projekt Goethe Zeit ist ne
das wäre nicht unbedingt die gleichen
sein die diese Interessen haben das
trifft selten zusammen trifft schon mal
zusammen aber dass man dann in diesen
Projekten fächerübergreifend gelernt ich
will so ein bisschen vom Fach Weg das
wahre Leben ist nicht sortiert wie so
ein Apothekerschrank in lauter Fächer
sondern in dem Projekt Goethezeit ja was
man da alles machen kann jemand der
Faust ja erst jetzt natürlich erst was
für Fortgeschrittene da ist alles drin
da gibt es da geht es um den
Kapitalismus da geht's
auf wirklich geistreiche Art und Weise
um Religion jetzt geht's um Liebe da
gibt es um macht ja da geht's um Gut und
Böse und das sind alles Dinge die man
wunderbar
zeigen kann also mich so ist ja das
personifizierte Geld ja ein paar womit
wir schon wieder bei Johnny Infantino
werden ja tatsächlich
aber das stimmt
Mephisto und der Faust ja aber das ist
so weil es ist die Kraft ja die
Böses will und gutes schafft richtig so
erklärt Adam Smith den Kapitalismus
jeder denkt an sich und nachher ist für
alle an alle gedacht ja und es ist eine
Auseinandersetzung Goethes ja mit einem
Smith Wohlstand der Nationen
und das ist zum Beispiel hochinteressant
dass das jetzt nicht alles nur so
esoterik ist sondern wie das miteinander
zusammenhängt das ist die
Frühindustrialisierung die auf die
Romantik trifft und so das ist
hochspannend
und was noch also wo zum Beispiel auch
dieser dieser letzter Punkt Richard
dieser ist wenn du heute dir ein
Handwerker anguckst Anspruchs von
Handwerks da muss der Abitur haben ja
Elektriker heute muss schlau sein der
muss was drauf haben natürlich muss er
was drauf haben aber gleichzeitig
alle Leute genau durch Abitur bringen
also das ist ja auch so ein Fetisch ja
das ist ein Fetisch und das Wasser als
allerwichtigste ist ja dass die
Voraussetzungen die man können muss um
ein guter Handwerker zu sein nämlich gut
mit seinen Händen umgehen ja dass sie in
der Schule überhaupt nicht gelernt wird
also das ist jetzt die fand der
vernachlässigste Teil der gesamten
schulbildung ist ist die ganze also
Schulbildung müsste doch eigentlich
Herzensbildung sein ein guter Mensch
werden ist ja nicht nicht wenig
das Leben kennen kommst immer wieder auf
die Situation
also okay ich verstehe du willst auf die
point aus welche Schule
infanti Inferno zu werden
[Gelächter]
Handwerk zu dem Handwerks Gedanken
zurückzukommen also wir wir verachten
das Handwerkern das ist ganz ganz
schlimm weil wir immer noch dieser
merkwürdigen Überzeugung sind dass
geistige Leistungen ja grundsätzlich
überlegene Leistung gegenüber
handwerklichen Leistungen sind aber gar
nicht sehen wie viel Intelligenz gutes
Handwerk braucht ich meine so wie es im
Moment organisiert ist würde sie eher
gar nicht rausfinden dass sie vielleicht
eine begabte Tischlerin ist richtig und
wenn du vielleicht auch aus dem
Elternhaus kommt wo den tischler-beruf
sowieso von Anfang an nicht angedacht
ist als denkbare Option und deswegen
wäre es natürlich wichtig dass der das
Image der Handwerksberufe endlich mal
dem entspricht was sie tatsächlich sind
und dass man nicht glaubt dass
Menschen die Berufe mit weißem Kragen
haben grundsätzlich überlegen sind
gegenüber Berufen mit blauem Kragen das
ist was was wir uns eigentlich überhaupt
gar nicht mehr leisten können
21 Jahrhundert passt das ist so das ist
ein Überbleibsel so ein Fossil der
Angestellten Gesellschaft des 20
Jahrhunderts das müsste verschwinden so
was ich mir noch Wünsche mehr Praktika
in die Schulen ja das Projekt Automotor
mit einem Kfz-Mechatroniker und nicht
unbedingt mit einem Lehrer ja ich will
die startup-gründer in der Schule haben
ja damit die die jungen Informatiker
hungrig machen
ich will ein Dichter in der Schule haben
der Gedichte beibringt ja also dass wir
diese diese künstliche Trennung von
Schule und leben dass wir die aufheben
ich möchte eine Schule unterteilen in
lauter eins in der lernhäuser wie ein
College das englische college-system ist
ja großartig und diese lernhäuser da
wird man eingeschult wenn man in die
Schule kommt und da bleibt man die ganze
Zeit drin und hat dann diese Lehrer die
sich um einen kümmern und deren Aufgabe
es ist ein so weit wie möglich zu
bringen irgendwann springt man die
Grenzen des lernhauses ne wenn das
Projekt Goethe Zeit angeboten ist dann
kommt man auch mit den anderen Kindern
zusammen das erweitert sich dann so
langsam aber man wird betreut ja also
Slytherin Griffin da und so weiter ja
also mehr Harry Potter in die Schule
genau und dann spielerisch Konkurrenz
gegeneinander nein nicht unbedingt Besen
reiten aber Theater Wettbewerbe
kopfrechenwettbewerbe von mir aus
Informatik wegbewerbe spielerische
Konkurrenz ja man wird später in den
meisten rufen nicht ganz alleine
arbeiten sondern immer irgendwo in
irgendeiner Form in Teams ist richtig
und das am besten schmieden sich Teams
zusammen wenn sie mit anderen Teams
spielerisch in Wettbewerb natürlich
genau genau spielerischer Wettbewerb ja
statt notentürerei das wäre auch noch
was was ich mir wünsche ist es doch
völlig egal in der zusammengewürfelten
Runde die sich deine Klasse nennt ja
bemisst sich ja deine Note am
Klassendurchschnitt nennt das Niveau der
Klausur an Klassendurchschnitt du kannst
gar nichts für den Klassendurchschnitt
du hast nichts damit zu tun aber deine
Note ist davon abhängig das ist
überhaupt diese diese Ziffern Zensuren
braucht man langfristig nicht mehr
differenzierte Bewertungen ja das wäre
in der Markus gut ist oder weniger gut
ist irgendwo noch mehr machen kann ja
das ist am Ende doch viel wichtiger und
entscheiden als ob du irgendwann mal in
irgendeinem Test in Chemie eine drei
oder eine 5 gehabt hast wirklich okay
boah das ist erst Absolution für vieles
was in meinem Leben in Sachen Chemie
schief gelaufen ist das größte mich
richtig und musste ich 50 Jahre alt
werden um das jetzt von dir so zu hören
bin ganz gerührt ich habe noch ganz kurz
eine Fraktion zu bekommen ja genau
machst du all das Richard in einer
Schuluniform oder nicht ja ich
Entschuldigung Uniform gut aber ich
werde natürlich ich bin ja gegen Zwang
ne ich würde ich würde jetzt mit den
Schulen ich würde jedenfall
nein
die Schule die Schule muss ich ja nicht
also wir führen jetzt nicht mal in
Nordrhein-Westfalen oder nach Hamburg
die Schuluniform ein sondern so moderne
aufgeschlossene Kulturminister ja die
gehen in die Schulen und erzählen
irgendwas ist alles für tolle Ideen gibt
ja und erstellen ihn wenn Sie möchten
auch Transformation Scouts an die Seite
die Ihnen helfen sich zu entwickeln in
eine spannende Richtung ja und zwar jede
Schule so wie sie will eine Schule in
einem wilden vor Ort vielleicht ein
bisschen anders als eine
brennpunktschule die andere Schüler hat
wo sie andere Fragen stellen und so
weiter und ein ein solcher Vorschlag
könnten Schuluniform sein ne die halbe
Welt trägt Schuluniform und Schule
Uniform die in der Identifikation
und nivellieren ein wenig die sozialen
Unterschiede und ich finde das erste
sogar noch wichtiger als das zweite dass
man einfach stolz ist auf seine Schule
oder sich zugehörig fühlt dass man dann
vielleicht auch noch ein paar andere
Streifen drauf hat je nachdem welchem
Lernhaus man ist und so das kann sehr
heilsam sein und ich glaube in
bestimmten Gegenden je nachdem wie die
Schülerschaft zusammengesetzt ist können
Schuluniformen sehr schlau sein aber das
muss die Schule dann eben selber
entscheiden
ja wenn du kann ich dir aus Erfahrung
sagen wenn du mit sehr wenig Geld
aufwächst dann wünscht du dir eine
Schule Uniform ja ist die Wahrheit ja
habe ich mir so oft gewünscht ja
wirklich weil das hätte vieles einfacher
gemacht ja in meinem Fall übrigens auch
weil bei uns zu Hause wurde auf Kleidung
kein Wert gelegt und das war in meiner
Pubertät ein erhebliches Problem in der
Schule und als ich dann im neunten
Schuljahr in England war im Schüler
Austausch ich begeistert von den
Schuluniform also da geht es mir wieder
ja genau also Richard wenn Du über Deine
Traumata in Sachen Schuluniform noch
weiter mit mir reden möchtest ruf mich
gleich an ja ansonsten danke ich dir
Absolution in Chemie kannst du auch noch
schriftlich haben wunderbar freue ich
mich ja das waren sehr schöner
austauschricher danke sehr hab einen
schönen Tag ja
[Musik]
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und potsdas
bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF